What I want to do in this video
is to talk a little bit about 401(k)'s
which you probably at
minimum have heard of.
Just from the get-go,
just to put some structure
in your mind of what this really is
is it's very similar to a traditional IRA.
It's very similar to a traditional IRA
and the ways that they're the same
is that you defer you taxes.
You put money in on a tax deferred basis.
Let me put it this way,
you put pretax money in.
The money can grow inside
of either the 401(k) account
or the traditional IRA account untaxed.
Let me write that,
money grows in account untaxed
and then you can withdraw it,
you can withdraw the money.
You can withdraw or start
getting distributions
from the account after age 59-1/2.
That's essentially when you're
going to start retiring,
when you're going to need the money.
When you withdraw after the age of 59-1/2
you will then pay income tax.
This is what people are talking about
when they talk about deferring taxes.
You're not getting out of the taxes,
you're just pushing off the date
that you're going to
have to pay the taxes.
For a lot of people this might be useful
because while you are making money,
you might be paying at a fairly high
incremental tax rate
but then once you're retired
you have a much lower,
you'll have a much lower,
I guess you'll be in a much
lower incremental tax bracket
and so your total overall
tax bill might be lower.
Also, maybe something happens
just in terms of what the government does,
in terms of how they charge taxes.
In general, if you had to pay 50 cents
20 years in the future
versus 50 cents today,
just present value of money tells you
that that 50 cents is going
to be worth a lot less
in the future
or the present value of it is a lot less.
That's some reasons to defer.
Of course, you're not just going to pay
on what you put in,
you will then also pay income
tax on what you've put in
and whatever grew.
You'll pay income tax on total disbursals.
In both cases,
you have to start taking disbursements
from your account by 70-1/2.
Penalties, let me write it this way.
Penalties, if you don't withdraw
or you don't start withdrawing
some of your funds by 70-1/2.
There's some special
cases if you're working
and all these type of things.
Now, what's happens if you
withdraw before age 59-1/2?
Before 59-1/2.
So far, everything I've listed is true
of both 401(k)'s and traditional IRAs.
If you withdraw before 59-1/2,
you are taxed on withdrawal.
On top of that, there's a 10% penalty
on all the funds you receive. 10% penalty.
This is what you have to think about
unless if you just say,
"Oh, I'm always just going to max out
"my traditional IRA or 401(k)."
You got to make sure
they're not going to want
that money before 59-1/2
because you might be
facing this 10% withdrawal.
These are all the cases that are the same.
The question is why do they both exist?
Why is there something
called a traditional IRA
and why is there
something called a 401(k)?
They both seem like a pretty good way
for me to defer taxes,
get earnings on my investment
in a taxed deferred way
and then pay it some future date
and they both force me to make sure
or they strongly suggest
that I shouldn't take out
my money before 59-1/2.
The ways that they're different,
let's focus on the differences,
the differences between the 2.
One is 401(k)'s have a higher limit
and if you're focused on 2010,
but these numbers keep changing.
In 2010 the 401(k) limit is $16,500
and that's for just what you contribute
into your 401(k).
This is for a 401(k).
While the IRA limit is $5,000.
This is an IRA.
One; 401(k), you can just
participate with more money.
Actually, in both of these cases,
as you approach your retirement,
after the age of 50.
Let me put that in the same thing
just so we're comprehensive.
Another similarity is that
you can accelerate or have higher,
you could have higher, I guess,
deposits into your account,
accelerate after 50.
Which just means you can put more money
than these limits that I have right here.
These are limits before you're 50,
after 50, between 50 and 59-1/2
when you can start withdrawing.
You can put a little
bit more money in that
and these are constantly moving targets.
The general idea is that
you can put more money
inside of a 401(k).
Now, the other difference is that a 401(k)
tends to be organized by your employer.
401(k) organized by employer.
Just, from your point of
view, that means 2 things,
One is the employer will often specify
the potential investments.
Specifies investments.
They'll actually run the
401(k) account for you.
Normally it will be held by someone else
but it will be for your
company, for company x.
The company gets to decide
the universe of investments
that you might be able to invest in.
The other thing, because
it's run by the employer,
the employer might match.
Which means for every dollar you put in,
they'll put another dollar
even they might go above matching
and you could actually go up to,
I think the current limits
are approaching $50,000
for the total of the
employee and employer match.
You can actually get a lot of,
I guess you could think of it,
leverage from putting in into a 401(k)
if you have a very generous employer.
The other difference,
this is really a superficial difference
because it's just what you see,
is that with the 401(k)
the money will be taken out
of your paycheck, you will never see it.
Taken out before paycheck.
While with a traditional IRA,
you will take the money,
invest it into a traditional IRA account
and when you report your taxes
it will be reported as a tax deduction
and so you won't have to pay tax on it.
Functionally they're the exact same thing.
When you think about the pros and cons,
if you have a 401(k), if the
option is available to you,
it's a pretty good option.
You're going to have higher limit.
You're going to have a
higher limit right over here
and your employer might match it.
Then the other thing,
and this doesn't come into plays a lot,
but there's also the option of borrowing
from a 401(k) without penalty.
Borrowing from a 401(k)
but you have to pay back
interest to the 401(k) account
if you did that and you cannot do that
with a traditional IRA.
Now, when you're looking
at all these you're like,
"Whoa!
"Why would anyone ever want
to do a traditional IRA?"
There's a couple of things.
One; you could do both.
Or the other thing is
with traditional IRAs
you have much more flexibility
on where you want to invest.
Maybe your company says
you can only invest in us,
you can only invest in
that company's stock.
In traditional IRAs you
can invest in anything.
Hopefully that clarifies
things a bit for you.